[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis einem schönen guten
abend wünsche ich ihnen was mach ich
dich heute alles passiert ist erfahren
sie von uns in den nächsten knapp 20
minuten und dabei werfen wir natürlich
auch einen blick auf die em der sport
von
unsere großen themen
niedrigere steuer beim gas kanzler
scholz will die mehrwertsteuer auf den
gasverbrauch auf 7 prozent senken
masern impfpflicht ist rechtens wer
beispielsweise eine kita betreuung
möchte muss die impfung nachweisen
entscheidet das bundesverfassungsgericht
und gold in rom tina punzel olena
handspring so synchron vom
drei-meter-brett wie sonst niemand und
damit zum em titel
die mehrwertsteuer auf die gass umlage
zu streichen hat nicht geklappt wegen eu
recht stattdessen kündigt der kanzler
scholz jetzt an dass die mehrwertsteuer
auf gas generell gesenkt werden soll von
19 auf 7 prozent
und zwar so lange wie es die gasanlage
gibt was jeder und jede dadurch sparen
sollen zeigt ihn karl hinterleitner
wie viel ist die bürger künftig kostet
das ist sagte mitschek klarer um kurz
nach zwölf verkündete der kanzler von
der gasanlage solle der staat nicht
profitieren die bundesregierung hat
deshalb heute entschieden die
mehrwertsteuer auf gasverbrauch zeitlich
befristet auf 7 prozent abzusenken mit
diesem schritt entlasten wir die
gaskunden insgesamt deutlich stärker als
die mehrbelastung die durch die umlagen
entsteht doch von deutliche entlastung
kann kaum die rede sein zwar spart ein
durchschnittlicher single haushalt durch
die mehrwertsteuersenkung pro jahr etwa
132 euro wird aber mit der gasanlage im
gegenzug mit 130 euro belastet bei einem
vier-personen-haushalt bringt die
steuersenkung im jahr
528 euro wäre die gasanlage für 518 euro
belastung sorgt der opposition links wie
rechts reicht gast nicht viele menschen
seien finanziell schon jetzt überfordert
die steuersenkung nütze da nur wenig die
gaspreise werden sich verdreifachen was
bringt dann eine mehrwertsteuersenkung
im kleinsten stelligen bereich
also das wird die bürger nicht entlasten
vorschlag der linken waren direkte
zahlungen direkte zahlungen ein winter
geld was nicht nur die gaspreise sondern
auch die gestiegenen
nahrungsmittelpreise und andere
ausgleich dass es insbesondere für
diejenigen mit kleinen und mittleren
einkommen dringend notwendig diese
mehrwertsteuersenkung ist nur ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein auch wenn
zusatzkosten aus der gasanlage jetzt vom
tisch sind unabhängig davon steigen die
preise für energie immer weiter
contra banerjee also unterm strich wird
mit der senkung der mehrwertsteuer er an
erstmal nicht entlastet ja richtig also
diese maßnahme die gleiche jetzt erst
einmal mehr oder weniger die belastungen
aus die wir durch die gas umlage auf die
steigenden gaspreise noch mal oben drauf
kommt und das ist eben noch keine echte
entlastung die muss noch kommen das
heißt es jetzt auch aus den eigenen
reihen der regierungskoalition und eben
aus der opposition vor allem für
besonders bedürftige rentnerinnen und
rentner werden dort genannt studentinnen
und studenten
sollte sollten auf jeden fall echte
entlastungsmaßnahmen noch kommen und
olaf scholz hat es in seiner
pressekonferenz ja auch schon
angekündigt die beratungen über ein
drittes entlastungspaket die sollen bald
beginnen dann muss sich die
bundesregierung aber auch den kopf
darüber zerbrechen woher das geld kommt
denn mit der aktion von heute kommt auf
jeden fall nicht mehr geld in die
staatskassen reihen des
bundesfinanzministerium hat mal grob
überschlagen für den zeitraum für den
die mehrwertsteuersenkung jetzt
angesetzt ist kostet das ganze den staat
rund fünf milliarden euro danke für
diese einordnung santala penalty
teure energie in lassen sparen
rationieren fragt auch maybrit illner in
ihrer gesprächsrunde um 22.25
un-generalsekretär gut herrisch und der
türkische präsident erdogan haben sich
heute nach lemberg mit dem ukrainischen
präsidenten seelands getroffen dabei
ging es auch um die sicherheit des
atomkraftwerks sa borussia das derzeit
unter russische kontrolle steht das
gebiet müsse entmilitarisiert werden
sagte görisch das getreide abkommen
nannte er nur den anfang diplomatische
bemühungen einer hebestreit berichtet es
ist eine geste die ausdrückt präsident
selensky ist nicht gewillt kompromisse
zu schließen will die gefallenen kämpfer
legte einen kranz ab die botschafter
opfer darf nicht vergebens sein deshalb
macht man sich über die chancen der
vermittlungsbemühungen von
un-generalsekretär
und des türkischen präsidenten erdogan
in der ukraine auch wenig illusionen
die ukraine bereitet gerade eine
gegenoffensive vor wild territorium
zurückerobern und russland braucht vor
dem september waren dort auch einen
sichtbaren militärischen erfolg nach
sechs monaten kampf
immerhin haben die verhandlungen ergeben
dass die regierung in kiew ein abkommen
über den ukrainischen getreideexport
festhalten will in den letzten wochen
und mehr als 20 beladene frachter
ablegen
presseecho.de seine korridor für den
weizenexport funktioniert viele schiffe
die seit kriegsbeginn hier fest lagen
können fahren andere kommen diese
deutschen rap toyoto rief junge hier so
deuten dass wir so ein schwerer brocken
sind die gespräche über die gespannte
lage rund um das atomkraftwerk sapori
sie wo immer wieder geschossen wird und
sich beide seiten gegenseitig vorwerfen
mit einer atomaren katastrophe zu
spielen
sollte die ukraine weiterhin das
kraftwerk beschließen könnten wir uns
überlegen die letzten beiden reaktoren
in den modus kalte reserve abzuschaffen
das würde der ukraine die möglichkeit
nehmen strom nach europa zu exportieren
der streitpunkt aparicio war in lemberg
wohl zu groß für eine diplomatische
überraschung vereinbart wurde dass die
türkei der ukraine beim wiederaufbau
helfen wird erst mal aber gegen die
zerstörung weiter
nach wochenlanger zwangspause hat die
bundeswehr den truppen austausch in mali
wieder aufgenommen rund 90 soldatinnen
und soldaten wurden mit einer zivilen
chartermaschine in das westafrikanische
land geflogen überflüge mit
bundeswehrmaschinen werden seit wochen
nicht von der malische militärregierung
genehmigt daraufhin hatte berlin
vergangenen freitag ein teil der mission
vorläufig ausgesetzt
für wen ist der zweite corona booster
sinnvoll die ständige impfkommission hat
ihre empfehlungen erweitern nicht erst
ab 17 jahren sondern schon 60 jährige
sollten sich die zweite
auffrischungsimpfung geben lassen die
immunisierung solle mit einem mr im
stoff und sechs monate nach der letzten
spritze oder einer erkrankung erfolgen
von der korona zur masernimpfung hierzu
gab es heute ein urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes die
nachweispflichten kitas und schulen ist
rechtens und bleibt in kraft eltern
hatten gegen das maß an schutz gesetz
geklagt dass es seit märz 2020 gibt
seitdem müssen kinder in kitas oder
schule und auch das personal
nachweisen dass sie gegen das impfen
virus geimpft oder davon gewesen sind
masern sind weit mehr als eine
kinderkrankheit sie sind hoch ansteckend
und können lebensgefährlich sein birgit
franke und christian von rechenberg der
garten ist die welt von familie jost
gilbert so und simon will garten
architektur studieren der weg führt über
die fachoberschule
doch ohne masernimpfung wird simon dort
nicht aufgenommen impfen kommt für die
familie nicht in frage zu groß die angst
um die gesundheit
konkret befürchtet dass es irgendwelche
nebenwirkungen gibt oder langzeitfolgen
oder so mit denen wir jetzt noch nicht
rechnen können das
bundesverfassungsgericht bestätigt heute
das maß an schutz gesetz weil der schutz
der ganzen gesellschaft das recht des
einzelnen auf körperliche unversehrtheit
überwiegt zustimmung vom marburger bund
die masern impfungen ist ein
erfolgsrezept hat schon viele millionen
menschen leben weltweit gerettet es ist
eben keine harmlose erkrankung deswegen
ist es gut und richtig dass wir hier die
impfungen weiter voranbringen doch
dieser auch ohne staatlichen druck
bereits gut vorangebracht sagen kritiker
wie michael friedl geringe todeszahlen
würden das belegen wir haben das
vorgelegt auch dem verfassungsgericht
wie welchen status wie schon in den
letzten 15 jahren erreicht hatten da
sind zwei todesfälle bei kindern bekannt
der beschluss heute auch eine
vorentscheidung für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht
das ist in diesem beschluss noch nicht
vor entschieden es gibt ansätze die man
weiterentwickeln konnte wo man sagen
könnte auch eine allgemeine impfpflicht
etwa gegen kurbelt ist gerechtfertigt
aber das gericht sagt auch er ist ein
ganz erheblicher eingriff und der
gesetzgeber muss gute gründe haben simon
justiert muss seine lebenspläne
jedenfalls ändern oder sich doch für das
impfen entscheiden
zum massiven fischsterben an der oder da
steht die genaue ursache immer noch
nicht fest forschende haben inzwischen
eine giftige algen atem blick die sich
im fluss rasant entwickelt hat jetzt
laufen untersuchungen ob sie der grund
für das fischsterben ist die ersten
toten tiere sollen bereits mitte juli in
polen entdeckt worden seien neuen
schätzungen zufolge sind insgesamt
bereits fast 140 tonnen fischkadaver
gefunden worden anja kling bei beginnt
ihren bericht in der nähe von schwedt in
brandenburg
der naturschutzbund unterwegs an der
ruder südlich von schwedt neben
unzähligen toten fischen finden die
experten auch viele verendete schnecken
und muscheln
muscheln haben eine große bedeutung für
die selbstreinigungskraft für die
biologische selbstreinigungskraft eines
flusses oder eines gewässers im
allgemeinen das heißt diese ganze
kostenlose biologische filter ist
komplett weggefallen nach der ursache
für diese katastrophe die das ganze
ökosystem der oder bedroht wird seit
tagen gesucht während auf polnischer
seite die fischkadaver im fokus stehen
hoffen deutsche forscher die
entscheidende substanz im wasser zu
finden so viel ist klar
industrieabwässer spielen eine rolle
diese salz brachten die inzwischen
offenbar von polen auch eigen eingeräumt
werden also eine gezielte und offenbar
genehmigte einleitung diese salz
frachten haben dazu geführt zusammen mit
temperatur und wenig wasser das die alge
sich sehr stark konzentriert hat und
dann wenn es diese toxine produzieren
alge ist entsprechend große mengen an
toxin die oder untergeschoben sind
anhaltspunkte aber ob es wirklich die
alge ist müssen aufwendige genetische
laboruntersuchungen erst noch bestätigen
man hängt das immer mehr ein und das
bedeutet bedeutet auch dass man sowohl
technische kapazität als auch was die
ausstattung angeht riesige labore
braucht dazu brauchte es für notfälle
wie die für eine bessere vernetzung der
deutschen labore fordern naturschützer
nicht nur sie fürchten dass das
ökosystem der oder auf jahre stark
geschädigt ist
ausbildungsplatz sucht azubi so spitzt
der deutsche industrie und
handelskammertag die situation vieler
betriebe in deutschland zu die lage auf
dem ausbildungsmarkt habe sich noch
weiter verschärft und sei noch nie so
schwierig gewesen mehr als vier von zehn
betrieben hätten im vergangenen jahr
nicht genug azubis gefunden gründe dafür
sind die korona pandemie und dass immer
mehr ältere in rente gehen
immer weniger azubis warum wollen viele
lieber studieren das ist thema bei zdf
heute live um 19.30 zu sehen in der
mediathek und in der zdf- heute
seit jahren streiten sich serbien und
kosovo immer wieder drohte die lage zu
eskalieren
die europäische union unternimmt heute
einen neuen versuch zwischen den beiden
ländern zu vermitteln
hintergrund die ungeklärte
grenzsituation
1999 spaltete sich das kosovo mit hilfe
der nato von serbien ab erklärte sich
2008 für unabhängig
die meisten staaten haben kosovo
anerkannt serbien aber bis heute nicht
betrachtet kosovo als abtrünnige provinz
mehr von wolf christian ullrich
hier im norden von kosovo wird überall
die serbische fahne und die autos
bekommen serbische kennzeichen die
kosovarische regierung will nun
durchsetzen dass autos die in kosovo
zugelassen sind auch kosovarische
nummernschilder haben für die menschen
hier geht es bei diesem streit ums
prinzip und um identität
wir fühlen uns wie ein teil serbiens
ohne serbien würden wir verschwinden wir
werden von serbien unterstützt ich
bekomme eine rente von
der kennzeichen streit ist so ein großes
politikum weil es im kern darum geht
dass serbien kosovo nicht als eigenen
staat anerkennt an der grenze hatte es
deshalb blockaden und spannungen gegeben
serbien steht kennzeichen aus für unsere
städte und erwartet dann auch noch vor
uns dass wir das akzeptieren und dann
erkennen
die eu versuchte heute ein drittes mal
mit kosovos ministerpräsidenten kurti
und serbiens präsidenten vujic den
streit zu lösen
ergebnislos weil vujic nichts tun will
was den anschein einer anerkennung von
kosovo hat mutig hat eigentlich gar kein
interesse die beziehungen mit dem kosovo
zu klären er hat viel interesse daran
die illusion aufrechtzuerhalten dass er
bereit wäre vielleicht doch irgendwann
mal ein kompromiss zu schließen wurde
schweiß der serbien kein eu mitglied
wird wenn es kosovo nicht anerkennt aber
vujic weiß auch die mehrheit der serben
sieht kosovo weiter als teil von serbien
und deshalb wird er diese grenze so
schnell nicht anerkennen
nach deutschland fest steht bekifft darf
man auch künftig nicht auto fahren auf
dem verkehrsgerichtstag in goslar wurde
aber heute darüber diskutiert ob der
grenzwert des cannabis wirkstoff thc
erhöht werden sollte dem man beim fahren
im blut haben darf die ampel koalition
hatte sich in ihrem koalitionsvertrag
auf eine kontrollierte abgabe von
cannabis geeinigt moritz gipfel über die
diskussion sie muss eine mpu machen eine
frau die unerkannt bleiben möchte bei
einer verkehrskontrolle hatte sie und
ein nanogramm des hanf wirkstoffs thc im
blut für sie eine böse überraschung denn
als sie sich ans steuer setzte fühlte
sie sich nüchtern und wichtig den joint
rauchte sie einen tag zuvor
bei alkohol weiß ich wann es abgebaut
ist im blut dass es bei thc ist er
schwer zu berechnen auch bei sehr
niedrigen werten wo man vielleicht von
gelegenheits konsum wenn überhaupt
ausgeht kann der mpu angeordnet werden
gerät man in eine kontrolle und wird thc
nachgewiesen ist man dran denn anders
als bei alkohol gibt es bei cannabis
kaum toleranz ob dies gerecht ist und
bestand haben kann wird aktuell beim
verkehrsgerichtstag in goslar diskutiert
alkohol und cannabis werden ungleich
behandelt das ist im moment aber auch
völlig korrekt weil das eine eine legale
droge ist und das andere eine illegale
probe doch das wird sich voraussichtlich
ändern die frage bleibt wie sich
cannabiskonsum auf die fahrtüchtigkeit
auswirkt die wenigen studien die sich
damit beschäftigen geben keinen
einheitlichen fingerzeig dafür könnte
ein blick in die nachbarländer helfen
die holländer haben mit guter erfahrung
drei nanogramm den finde ich auch
richtig bisher haben wir die
nachweisgrenze von einem nanogramm das
ist also nicht so wahnsinnig viel mehr
spätestens mit der legalisierung von
cannabis braucht es klare regeln für den
straßenverkehr wie diese aussehen
könnten offen die experten des
verkehrsgerichtstages jedenfalls werden
dem gesetzgeber ihre empfehlungen dazu
morgen geben
kommen wir zur schwimm-wm in rom norbert
da gab es ja schon wieder gold für
deutschland ja einen tag nach ihrem sieg
im mixed synchronspringen hat tina
punzel zusammen mit ihrer partnerin lena
henschel auch den wettbewerb vom drei
meter brett gewonnen die siebte
goldmedaille der dresdnerin bei
europameisterschaften
em titel erfolgreich verteidigt tina
punzel und lena henschel triumphieren im
römischen foro italico vom drei meter
brett ich bin total glücklich
erleichtert es hat super viel spaß
gemacht heute auch ihren sogenannten
problem sprung den zweieinhalb auerbach
salto gehechtet bringen die berliner und
die dresdnerin souverän ins wasser als
favoritinnen im finale hatten die
deutschen von sprung 1 an über alle fünf
durchgänge in führung gelegen deutlicher
sieg für kuntzl und henschel vor den
springerinnen aus italien und schweden
der ehemalige weltklasse wasserspringer
jan hempel wirft seinen verstorbenen
trainer werner langer sexuellen
missbrauch vor er soll sich an hempel
seit seinem elften lebensjahr zeitweise
täglich vergangen haben 14 jahre lang
auch während der olympischen spielen
unter 92 in barcelona unmittelbar vor
einem wettkampf
und als reaktion hat der deutsche
schwimm verband heute den wassersprung
trainer und ehemaligen jugend
bundestrainer lutz busckow von seinen
aufgaben freigestellt
laut hempel soll busckow die aufklärung
der missbrauchsvorwürfe mit verhindert
haben
und zu den european championships da ist
im siebenkampf der frauen
medaillenhoffnung soviel weißenberg als
fünftplatzierte vor dem abschließenden
800 meter lauf ausgestiegen gute
bedeuten den chancen dagegen für die
stabhochspringer
das deutsche stabhochsprung trio
erreicht geschlossen das morgige finale
wo kann dieter bähre oleg zernicke und
torben blech überqueren mühelos die
qualifikationshöhe von 5 metern 65
in 200 meter halbfinale sprintet
alexandra burghardt genau wie jessica
bianca was soll i die mit 23,14 sekunden
saison bestzeit läuft
joshua abo akku steht im 400 meter
hürden finale wie auch carolina
kraffzick bei den frauen
und olympiasiegerin und weltmeisterin
die hamburger kämpft heute abend im
weitsprung gold danke
an den alten beginnt es morgen früh
heftig und lange anhalten zu regnen wie
es in den anderen regionen aussieht
erfahren sie gleich von katja honnefer
das heute-journal können sie um 21 55
sehen mit anne gellinek bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend wir nennen so ein tief eine
genozid lohne weil er sich über genua
bildet unter langsam ostwärts zieht von
den alpen ein bisschen aufgehalten wird
und seine energie aus dem warmen
mittelmeer wasser zieht das hat nämlich
zurzeit dauert temperaturen von 26 27
grad auch bei uns auf der deutschen
seite der alpen auf der nordseite also
gibt es ergiebigen dauerregen der selbst
schon morgen früh ein kräftige gewitter
gibt es in der nacht im nordosten die
temperaturen sinken in berlin nicht
unter 20 grad sonst wird es deutlich
kühler im westen und im süden da sinken
die werte auf 15 bis 12 grad und morgen
liegen die höchsttemperatur meister bei
23 bis 30 grad am wärmsten wird es dabei
mittelrhein ganz anders am alpenrand
werden kaum die 18 bis 22 grad erreicht
in norddeutschland ziehen diese
regenschauer und gewitter hier im osten
weiter nordwärts raus dann wechseln
sonne und wolken ab nachmittags kommt
neue schauer im westen und im süden gibt
es dann diesen mit gewittern durchsetzt
dauerregen und besonders heftig schüttet
es an den alpen es drohen schlammlawinen
und überflutungen auch am samstag regnet
es dort noch kräftig weiter danach
beruhigt sich das wetter guten abend